tout va bien ça va mais on a droit de
fumer
ici les invités peuvent fumer bien sûr
c'est les animateurs qui peut on me dire
en belgique même les invités et d un
petit peu des soucis sifaoui c'est ça il
ya le csa g christine landes sur le
clean week est le signe d'accord et
c'est bien sûr fait mais comme tu veux
les styles mais absolument tester les
cyclistes à rougemont et m6 et m6 avant
mais attention donc enfin moi je n'aime
pas ça va les gars bien
bon alors après on va écouter ce que
vous avez chanté après un cousin cousine
aulas qui répondraient ça lui est resté
complètement je voulais laisser entre
jouer laurent michel les enfants
s'amusent michel je vous en fait on a
expliqué il est avec nous vous êtes en
est très heureux de vous avoir
non mais vraiment je ne crois je les
aime coucher savez que je suis à moscou
- mais non écoulés ce genre de questions
islamistes
si vous allez vous coucher tôt mon
devoir d'être vieux c'est le cas mais
non
vous partirez avant la chanson si l'on
voulait non je veux aller coup je suis
vraiment mais chez elle à travers mes
chers et que nous on était heureux de
nous avoir fait moins clavel et dit je
ne veux pas être censuré un truc de télé
qu'on puisse repasser en même pas un
truc comme ça voulait dire qu'arthur
façon les enfants de la télé dans le dix
ans parce que c'est ce qui va passer
ouais ouais ouais dans la la je vous dis
je je n'ai plus rien à dire je trouve
vous amuser comme des jeunes fous et je
trouve que c'est pas la peine que je
reste là c'est à cause de calixte
bonjour je pense qu'elles n'ont rien
c'est à cause de calix auquel j ai déjà
dieudonné cas pas voulu venir à cause de
sébastien c'est toujours un peu peur
quand je la vois pas ce qu'elle sort des
grosses conneries alors ça met de
mauvaise humeur voilà c'est un peu à
cause de calixte alors j'aime pas cessé
ses grandes propositions de loi ça
m'énerve beaucoup fabriquer ce qu'ils
avaient ça vaut quoi vous avez fait
prendre et pensez vous partez quand
quelqu'un peut vous apporter la
contradiction est plus ça maintenant non
mais c'est pas une question de
contradictions non non non mais je sais
qu'elle est toujours à prendre des
positions extrêmes et ça me fatigue
terriblement n'ont pas poussé michel que
vous étiez venu un jour à une émission
ou sur tv5 on nous avait expliqué que je
vous étiez contre la contraception pour
les noirs parce que c'est une façon de
faire un génocide des noirs ça m'a
tellement exaspéré depuis je veux plus
vous entendre qu'elle était contre la
contraception pour les noirs bah oui
parce qu'elle disait que c'était comme
jeannette vermeersch il faut que les
pros l'air
il faut que les prolétaires faisait
pourquoi on fait mieux que la job et que
dire des conneries depuis tout à l'heure
je ne dis rien
voyez mais j'aimerais que vous allez
vous taire la mer mais le reste du temps
je dois monsieur moi je n'ai jamais dit
ça c'est pas vrai monsieur vous le
vainqueur donc je suis désolé c'est déjà
ça
je vous ai expliqué tout simplement
qu'en afrique y avait des régions
on ne pouvait pas développer l'économie
de kanaker parce qu'ils avaient une
sous-population pourquoi au gabon et à
700 milles habitants avec ses 5000
habitants vous ne pouvez pas bâtir
réellement une économie des capotes
non je n'ai pas dit
pas du tout n'était pas question mais de
4000 de rien du tout mais vous avez dit
que l'afrique était surpeuplé c'est ce
que tu avais dit et c'est vous qui avez
raconté une grosse connerie on va vous
laisser je suis entend débourser support
papier et je supporte pas c'est calixthe
belaya c'est que elle fasse des livres
avec les livres des autres des condamnés
avaient trop honte
c'est ce à quoi et moi je ne devrais
avoir honte à votre place parce que vous
êtes en train de vraiment vous êtes vous
montrer mais vraiment je vous respecte
énormément et vous montrer d'une
médiocrité
je suis désolé forcément finalement cédé
que de l'apparence
ah bon
ma mère maman ma mère bon reste que je
vous fais peur non pas si ça sera pas
drôle ce sera prêt non mais c'est bon
vous emmener comme ça pendant toute la
soirée effectivement vous mais pas
agressé avait agressé bah oui parce
qu'un suspect est assez petit bassin il
a géré ça suffit vous savez ce qui vous
habite la haine la haine qui est à
revoir nos jours et spécialiser les
personnes mais je respecte les écrivains
[Applaudissements]
plus à partir de maintenant
non ils ne dérangent pas moi non plus ça
me dérange pas de lundi
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus